America's worst press secretary in
history is going Vogue Karin Jean-Pierre
getting a glowing profile in the liberal
fashion mag chock full of all the
identity politics Hallmarks like did you
know she's the first black person and
first openly gay person to hold the
position we also learned how there was
no actual interview process to hire kjp
and Joe Biden only talked to her for
about 20 seconds all right Dana did you
get a Vogue profile no and you are just
as good of a dresser as kjp if not sure
they would disagree
um
usually don't probably interview for
that job because you have done like I
was the deputy for a long time and I
filled in often and I was with the
president a lot for two and a half years
as the deputy and then I became the
press secretary but no conservative
women never get these things and and
good for her I mean it's a great picture
wonderful I did think it was kind of
interesting though because I used to get
up at 4 12 in the morning in the article
it says she gets up at 4 30 in the
morning but I'm I don't know why that's
necessary because 43 was in the Oval
Office by 6 a.m that's why we got up at
four in the morning
here's a brunch list he has a brunch lid
so I don't know why they're up so early
so they're up early because that's when
the real president is in and then when
Joe comes yeah he goes home who goes
home go ahead Greg oh I it's always been
an issue with me is that she doesn't
appear to try that's because because she
was bequeathed this it's like it's like
when you're working with somebody who
really doesn't care going back to the
earlier block if Artemis is a woman then
I am a black lesbian and I demand to
have a Vogue cover or a Vogue feature on
myself Harold and you can be my date oh
you'll clutch your binder like this
fierce
a powerful women all right uh your
thoughts on kjp's glowing profile
um I I've said before I agree with Dana
I think they've been better press
secretaries but I'm not going to knock
her at all for
seems I'm looking forward to reading it
and maybe I'll learn it maybe I'll learn
a few things I do one of the things that
Dana said I think that is often
overlooked in politics in the last
couple of Cycles is that you want
someone in these key jobs so you have a
close relationship with and you trust
who understand you and have been around
you this is not a knock on kjp at all
but there I think as you look at even
what president Trump some of his early
appointments people he didn't have a
long-term relationship with I think it's
important in any Administration that you
know the person that the person knows
you and has a good understanding and
feeling for the things you're trying to
get accomplished hopefully some of that
comes out in the article I'm not so sure
she has great access to the president
judge ah well the the interesting thing
about her getting up at 4 30 in the
morning is this she's got 10 hours
before the briefing usually at about 2 2
30 and the answers are the same I'll
Circle back with you I can't answer that
that's a hashtag violation I've made it
clear the president has made it clear
why is she getting up at 4 30. it's all
the same answer and 5 finally
um you know I think that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders that hers was a historic
achievement she was the first full-time
working mother to serve in that capacity
very nice they did nothing on her I have
to say binder does dress well she does
and I will give her that but her problem
is she you can't read this is what Tyra
said you can't read while talking to
somebody because it just you only have
one part of your brain that can work and
that's why she's having a problem maybe
she should wake up at 1 40. she should
wake up before she goes to bed that
sounds good
the verge of a breakthrough
that it's going to let you speak to your
pets
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else